And in this case, the correct answer is that class
diagram and deployment diagrams are the only two UML structural
diagrams among these four. So the answer to this quiz
was probably pretty obvious, but I wanted to use it
also to stress, once more, the difference between structural and
behavioral diagrams. Structural diagrams provide the static picture of the
system being modeled, presented from different perspective. For example, from
the perspective of the class diagram and of the deployment diagram.
Behavioral diagrams, on the other hand, provide information on
the dynamic behavior of the system being modeled, also
presented from different perspective. So it's important to be
able to distinguish between these two types of diagrams. This
concludes this lesson on object orientation and UML. But
I encourage you to look at the references provided
in the class notes, in case you want to
know more about object orientation, object oriented analysis, and UML.